[Music]
in freaky furniture news Oh No submitted
by JK Familia million a thrift store
warned certain furniture may be haunted
I believe it I'm not coming here all
thrift store furniture that's how I feel
I don't shop at the thrift store
cosmetics stores creeped me out so Meryl
had this antique key card at her house
she just sold it recently tea cart thank
[ __ ] god because that [ __ ] creep me
the [ __ ] out
did it look freaky like it came from a
scary movie it just looks old and
battered you know has like character to
it right but I always feel weird about
something that's been owned for like a
hundred years yeah you don't know what
would happened in a house I don't
necessarily even think it's haunted but
just if that person had like a really
strong energy that owned it something
about their shoes you like something
weird about it's like they just took a
[ __ ] on it with their energy exactly
it's not like that it's a ghost and then
it's like haunted it's like walking
around like how we feel with the house
it is just looking at houses do you feel
it yeah but you know what I want to do
is what if like there's a really
talented musician that played this piano
and then like every time you play it
they can possess you that's what I want
don't be so tight that's like I get to I
get to be really good without the work
what if I could just go to Stevie
Wonder's piano and I can go no but like
let's say he gave me his piano and I
just play like him all of sudden I'll be
so sick just practice really hard you'll
never get to his level I'll never get
there that's the problem
never ever yes I do it's like the matrix
you know you're not sleeping in that I
want to go like this to the moon but the
moon's over here that's like the Eiffel
Tower picture this thrift store just a
Chicana these three store no they were
posting on social media this warning
warning it's haunted yeah restore of
Rowan County they've posted a queen
canopy bed frame and a highboy chest of
drawers highboy yeah so they're saying
that the previous owners said that it
was very haunted why did they destroy
here I know what cuz people don't you
know believe in that stuff because
they're they're all so cheap but he
believed but they believed in it they
were like it's really haunted but let's
give it to someone else because they're
cheap and they're like the thrift store
would take it for five dollars I don't
think the baby is what does it person
that you can only get rid of it if
someone accepts ah what about thrift
stores buy clothes I thought they did
too but every time I'd donate stuff they
don't pay me maybe you don't they give
you a receipt so you could do a tax
write-off oh yeah they do that the
Salvation Army yeah so these are the
pizzas so there's they're talking about
- it looks freaky particular is what's
haunted that should look like Beauty the
beast roars open on their own no so this
is what the note says they're still
gonna charge a thousand dollars yeah
well it depends if it's really bad
highboy chest of drawers hand-carved in
the 1950s please no previous owner
reports that the highboy is haunted he
reports continuous nightmares for he and
his wife while it was in their room he
also reports that the dogs would not
start barking at whoa
well edrick would be down for it oh for
sure I can't wait I need a ghost let me
buy that [ __ ] real quick what if what if
you advertised in like like warning this
this is haunted by a really hot ghost
that climbs out and sucks your dick
I'm buying that for $2,000 because
people were obviously very interested in
this and I was a couple who bought it
already yeah there's like those weird
people that was Ricky and his partner do
they have nightmares
um well the last so when they were
reporting this they were interviewing
them in the thrift store like purchasing
it uh so we don't know I want to know if
they have nightmares yeah it's kind of
like those people that go out of their
way to be extra demon II and weird and
in witchy
you know those guys the girl the girl
graveyard girl did you ever see Shane's
when she did they shamed it a whole like
Rocky
series on her and she like loves going
to this haunted store and like it's like
a store specifically that sells like
haunted items and she buys things from
it and so she was like a collection of
haunted items and she brought this one
doll and like ever since she got it like
like crazy stuff what happens and she
enjoys it
like what like her to her car flooded
from this random like fluke like in the
car and then that was the first day that
she had it and then the second but does
she have a Honda Element though cuz if
she did it's pretty normal I don't think
it was I think it was just uh howdy or
something it's just that one particular
item yeah that that doll total one not
because she loves like going to the
haunted store place I bet you did stuff
I'm going to talk about the Halloween
store do you know about the museum that
um what's that guy with the tattoos on
his face uh uh no he's a rapper um oh my
god o-69 Takashi goddammit he's really
popular right now okay no yah yah
yes okay you know that bad [ __ ] that
happened to him no my kid like people
his friends started dying and like it's
like feeling numbers and stuff okay well
he went to this haunted place in but
like on the way to Las Vegas there's
this museum that has like hauntings you
know in black mirror they have like it's
a real one like that and it has like
hunter pilant everything like we don't
watch black mirrors okay so there it's
like a museum with like haunted us
things like either it's spiritually
haunted or like it's just like weird
like it was used in internment camps or
like torture devices like [ __ ] like that
that's all weird but there is a room
that's specifically like a potent like
these items are so messed up that like
you're not a lot of touch them and he
touched one and then all this bad [ __ ]
started happening to him Wow googly
googly oh yeah Google that [ __ ] it's
crazy cuz it's like but he also became a
rapper too so it kind of helped I don't
even want to step foot in that place you
think that was like while he was on tour
or it was a cursed haunted that helped
him become popular
he was already I think
who bucks and then all this crazy [ __ ]
happened to him my cochlear cuz he's
like oh I can't touch it you know Oh
sounds like something stupid I would do
it's Yiddish for malicious spirit the
boxes believe it's a Jewish spirit it's
believed to be the most haunted object
in the world and it's a near Las Vegas
desert covered with the protective
casing you have to be 18 and over and
sign a waiver just to see it but since
he's a celebrity they let him see it
without the protective casing what on
there's video of him touching it yeah
what does that mean now what's the stuff
that happened though like did like who
died like what happened first my might
have been diluted by the time the evil
Jewish man start [ __ ] pop-locking his
[ __ ] I am going to do your taxes the
oddest mountain comes up yeah yeah I
don't know the specifics but I just know
like some crazy shits because sometimes
people oh it says he boarded a private
plane to London have only to have the
tires blown off immediately after
takeoff the pilot managed to land a
plane safely
well that's [ __ ] up curse because the
pilot didn't do nothing armed robbers
broke into a house where Malone used to
live and demanded to see him fortunately
he wasn't there but that's rapper Kurt
that's rapper Karma yeah that's replica
go to the box then see what happens if
his eyebrow fell off on my oh [ __ ]
that box is crazy yeah so far certain
things there like for example like a
rapper trying somebody trying to rob a
rich rapper it's very common very very
common you know so it's like yeah I
don't know about that but if he was
walking around and six of his teeth fell
out and when they fell out they spelled
why'd you touch it yeah so I just broke
into other little teeth and goes why'd
you touch it and then they then they run
away and then run away or if you took a
[ __ ] on the plane and then the plane
toilet sucked his intestines out of his
[ __ ] into the thing it's a final
destination stuff that's some crazy [ __ ]
yeah but you know it'd be so funny what
if like he went into the plane bathroom
and he went to wash his face and when he
looked up there was a ghost there but
he's uglier than the ghost of the ghost
rides away
[Laughter]
[ __ ] out of there it's like I quit
crying or rather the ghost crosses our
work yeah I'm gonna have anybody fly
their big brother ghost comes over like
why'd you do that man what's a fly why'd
you steal with your face buddy I'm just
on a personal note you know I used to be
a big hater a post Malone and then I
started listening to some more of his
music and I was like oh he's actually a
pretty dope musician yes he's very
musical really dope he's just I just did
wasn't that emo rap at the time I think
it's acquired taste it took me a while
took me a while to kind of tunnel I hear
I'm out and have my ears beautiful I
thought he was like full-on black boy
he's you wish he didn't touch the box
directly by the way his friend touched
it and then touched his friend well it's
like Spanish omelet friend I yeah what
happened to the friend broke nine of his
fingers well he's only got a couple days
left probably days remember I never
watched a I gotta watch it dude I can't
remember my friends would call me and do
that [ __ ] you wouldn't want you won't
watch it with me okay I've already seen
it
but what if I'd ever seen it watch it
the creepy the creepy part is the girl
though oh the closet oh it in the
[ __ ] inside the hair yeah when
they're do you shower that should God
like take a shot with your eyes open and
[ __ ] yeah I still do that to this day I
see my movie we know from Freddy Krueger
yeah like if there's like if there's
some pretty shop where make sure that it
never falls down cuz I'm like my head
this way so the water hits here and it
always goes down I'm like I stopped
allowing TVs in my room after the ring
like no more TVs are allowed in them do
you remember that scene of Freddy
Krueger where the girls riding him and
our kitties are going oh no well do you
remember
they're gonna say the best of one where
he like comes into the show I actually
have never seen pretty good there's a
budget no no there's one where there's
there's titties we were able to rent
that at the library back in the day so
when we saw were like oh my god and then
we had to pause that [ __ ] to rewind and
just leave it there and then it was like
a bunch of kids wait why did you ask me
like we're gonna bond off of that money
I didn't know anyone else that watched
it but I wouldn't remember that scene
cuz I didn't get off on that had every
timestamp of every movie that had
titties in it that like some kid plan
together
yeah but basically during that scene we
paused it and all the kids were just
[ __ ] running around in circles like
oh my god that's a [ __ ] Katie I
remember that moment when I saw species
that's a team I don't watch maybe that's
the name of the website that's it I
don't know she's a very beautiful
actress but she was an alien right but
then she took the form of a hot girl but
she would just be murdering these dudes
like oh [ __ ] who's the tiger blood
what's his name Charlie Sheen's ex y ou
didn't Denise
Richard oh maybe she was hot as [ __ ]
though I remembered they were so big
maybe not her oh she was hot dog
[Music]